en esta ocasión quiero hablarles acerca
de el concepto de
aceleración
[Música]
acel
ración que probablemente ya ustedes ya
están familiarizados con esto la
aceleración
Es el
cambio cambio de
velocidad
velocidad durante un
tiempo durante un tiempo
dado quizá El ejemplo más típico si es
que les interesan los autos es que en
las revistas deportivas o en los eventos
donde hay carreras de automóviles les
dirán las cantidades de aceleración como
parte de las estadísticas de los autos
de carrera
encontrarán algo así como no sé me voy a
inventar una marca
un
Porsche
9111 que va de cer
a
60 millas por
hora que normalmente esto se abrevia
mph
en 3
segundos aunque esta primera parte que
les dan esto de 60 millas de 0 a 60
millas por hora es la rapidez o la
velocidad si fuera la velocidad tendrían
que indicarles la
dirección Bueno Cuál va a ser la
aceleración aquí acabamos de Ver la
definición que es el cambio de velocidad
durante el tiempo entonces la
aceleración como estamos hablando de
velocidades y la velocidad es un vector
la
también va a ser un
vector y es igual al cambio usamos la
Delta para indicar el cambio en este
caso es el cambio de
velocidad del vector
velocidad durante el tiempo que también
aquí podríamos ponerle la Delta porque
es el cambio en el tiempo pero bueno
podemos segir manejándolo con la t
solita para simplificar noos un poco
aquí la escritura de estas
así que bueno con este ejemplo tenemos
que vamos a cambiar de calor color para
darle variedad el cambio en la velocidad
Bueno nos dicen que va de 0 a 60 millas
por h la velocidad final es 60 millas
por h la velocidad inicial es 0 entonces
60 - 0 velocidad final menos velocidad
inicial Ese es el cambio o la diferencia
en velocidad todo esto son
millas por hora y como es velocidad
vector tengo que indicar la dirección
vamos a suponer que van a la derecha A
la
derecha y cuál es el cambio en el
tiempo el cambio en el tiempo viene
siendo 3
segundos viene 3
segundos así
esto nos viene dando o es igual a bueno
60 men 0 60 60 / 3 es
20 voy a escribir las unidades millas
por hora de otra manera van a ser
millas por
hora y por segundo o sobre segundo
Entonces lo voy a poner aquí por segundo
estas unidades las unidades en la
aceleración son bastante extrañas esto
Qué significa que este coche va a
acelerar cada segundo va a acelerar una
velocidad o va su cambio en velocidad va
a ser de 20 millas por hora cada segundo
este auto va a aumentar su velocidad en
20 millas por
hora Ah y no olvidemos escribir a la
derecha porque tenemos que seguir
manteniendo la notación del vector o
respetando que es un
vector bueno Tenemos aquí las unidades
millas por hora por segundo y bueno
también podemos verlo o podemos escribir
de manera que estas unidades o esta
parte del tiempo se
exprese sea igual a
millas Esto es lo mismo que bueno millas
por hora entre segundo estas es lo mismo
que si
escribo
millas por
hora por
segundo Sí porque Bueno si ustedes
recuerdan Cómo este manejar o dividir
estas tipos de unidades esto puedo es
ponerlo como segundos entre uno y bueno
si multiplico esta parte por esta y esta
por
esta y esta parte va hacia arriba
millas y estas dos van en el denominador
hora por
segundo pues me queda estas millas hora
por segundo lo que bueno pues no suena
muy lógico va un auto acelerando a 20
millas por hora segundo pues como que no
suena muy muy lógico podemos englobar
esta parte de las unidades en una sola
unidad Aunque no es obligatorio se puede
dejar expresando así entonces voy a
querer multiplicar esto de manera que
pues me elimine esta parte de las horas
Entonces qué podemos hacer pues
multiplicar
esto
por unidades que sean horas u hora
sobre segundo no me puedo ahora sí que
quiero transformar estas horas en
segundos y bueno Esto es lo mismo
Cuántas eh Cuántos segundos hay en una
hora bueno son
3600 y Cuánta fracción de hora y en un
segundo
es un
3,600 avo eh de hora entonces hago esta
multiplicación con esto yo estoy
eliminando esta parte esta unidad de las
horas y esto me va a quedar igual a
20 entre
3600 y ahora me van a quedar
millas por por segundo por
segundo segundo por
segundo y bueno estas unidad como que
también no suena muy lógica Pero bueno
aquí podemos simplificarlo quitar este
cero dividir entre dos cada una de estas
partes igual nos queda a
un
18o
de
millas por por segundo al
cuadrado entonces Bueno es es el
resultado esto es la aceleración de este
auto una forma más clara de verlo es si
ustedes se imaginan aquí el velocímetro
más o menos lo voy a
dibujar Tenemos aquí este donde va a
estar moviéndose la aguja y Tenemos
aquí vamos a ver más o menos
así por ejemplo aquí va
10 20
50 60 Aunque bueno Esto realmente no
sería como el velocímetro de un porsch
podría ser el velocímetro de un auto así
normal que pueden ver en la calle y aquí
antes de arrancar tenemos que pues está
la velocidad es cero cuando pasa
transcurre un segundo si es que nuestro
auto tiene una aceleración constante
aunque normalmente Pues no va a ser así
pero imaginé para la claridad de este
ejemplo cuando transcurre un segundo
este mi velocímetro va a haber
cambiado o sea va a ha acelerado mi
coche durante cuando pasó un segundo
ahora va a estar a 20 millas por
hora pero millas por segundo No si
millas por hora en un segundo pasa otro
segundo transcurre otro segundo y ahora
la velocidad de mi coche va a haber
aumentado a 40 si pasa otro segundo
entonces la velocidad ahora estará aquí
cada segundo aumenta 20 millas por hora
la
velocidad m